what's up everyone eternals opening up
november 5th worldwide and there is a
lot of stuff out there right now reviews
are already out there there's
featurettes uh there's trailers they're
behind the scenes there's content
creators creating all this great stuff
just try to give you the information you
need to see eternals and to understand
it because these were very popular
characters in the marvel universe and in
the mcu we really have no reference to
gauge this off of because well i could
say guardians of the galaxy vol 1 volume
2 there's reference to celestials and of
course peter quill's father ego played
by kurt russell he was a celestial but
that's it and there's not even a mention
of that in eternal so
eternals is going to be a brand new film
for a lot of you out there but what i
wanted to do is i wanted to break things
down to the simplest form to compare the
eternal's powers to characters you have
seen in the marvel cinematic universe so
it makes it very easy for you so when
you watch the movie you have some sort
of comparison to kind of go off of so
with that let's kick off this video
first off we've got icarus icarus is the
guy that's in the blue suit flying
around in all the trailers of course
played by richard madden and he's
shooting laser beams out of his eyes
he's very strong who does he remind me
of iron man now of course iron man needs
a suit to do all these things icarus
does not
but when you watch the film a lot of his
movements will remind you of iron man
next is kingo played by kumal nanjani
and he's very similar to icarus except
he doesn't fly around and doesn't shoot
laser beams out of his eyes but he does
shoot these sort of laser beams and
power forces out of his fingers and out
of his hands he can create these these
balls of energy and fire them off at
deviance kind of looks like a like when
you're playing street fighter kind of
that same thing but to me in the marvel
cinematic universe if i was to compare
him to another character i would say
he's between two captain marvel and iron
man now he doesn't need a suit like iron
man and he doesn't fly like captain
marvel but his powers when you see in
the film are very similar to those two
characters that we've seen in the mcu
thus far
next we've got makari who is the speed
demon of the group who will she remind
you of in the marvel cinematic universe
dot dot quicksilver in avengers age of
ultron that's right his powers are very
similar to makari's and we also saw
another version of quicksilver in one
division as well played by another actor
but again the powers are very similar
speed and she is really badass next
we've got dina played by angelina jolie
the warrior of the group she's badass
she's a wicked fighter and she can also
recreate these weapons out of power and
out of nowhere so she can create swords
and shields and whatever she needs to
fight her opponent so who does she
remind me of well if you watch thor
ragnarok hella thor's half-sister
daughter of odin she reminds me of her
played by kate blanchett so and also
valkyrie and you could say a little bit
of black widow there as well so between
all those three that is dina next we got
sprite now sprite's powers in the comics
are a little bit different than we see
in the movie in the movie they sort of
simplified as she creates these
illusions out there and what she does
sometimes in the movie is create
multiple versions of herself to sort of
um
to uh decept the bad guys if she needs
to do that or if she wants to create
fireworks or display to sort of tell a
story she's really great at doing those
things so who does that remind you of in
the mcu
doctor strange remember in avengers
infinity war when doctor strange was
fighting thanos and he recreated
multiple versions of himself to fight
thanos same concept that's what sprite
does next let's talk about fastos played
by brian tyree henry now he is sort of
the engineer the brains of the group so
who would he remind you of in the marvel
cinematic universe you may say tony
stark and you could be right but i also
would say bruce banner as well so a
combination of tony stark bruce banner
is
fastos
next let's talk about gilgamesh who is
the bronze of the group the brawler of
the group who will he remind you of in
the marvel cinematic universe possibly
hulk now of course he doesn't turn green
he doesn't get big and he doesn't roar
talk like that but he's pretty badass
and he can throw a deep punch just like
the hulk can so i would say gilgamesh is
very equivalent to the hulk but he's not
as big next we got a druid played by
barry kilgan and he has the ability to
control people's minds so who in the
marvel cinematic universe does that
remind you of
if you thought about wanda in one
division the scarlet witch you're
correct they have the very similar
powers in that regard but one also has
some other powers that resemble some
other eternals which we'll talk about
right now cersei played by gemma chan
cersei has this ability to manipulate
matter to turn it into other things so
as you can see in the trailer she turns
ground into water she can turn a bus
into rose petals she has these this
innate ability to do all these great
things so who does that also remind you
of actually wanda from one division
remember how wanda created this whole
town and recreated all the clothing and
the homes and everything she created
this all from her mind
very similar to what cersei does so i
would say cersei and druid have the
powers of wanda or aka the scarlet witch
next we have ajax played by soma hayek
and her power is the power of healing
right so she can heal herself or
others but in the marvel cinematic
universe we really haven't seen anyone
with the power to heal others but they
can heal themselves case in point
captain america super soldier's serum
he's able to heal himself if he gets
beat up he can heal relatively quickly
but he doesn't have the power to heal
others but he can heal himself so i
would say that would be the closest to
ajax but of course her power is to heal
others out there and that is basically
the cast of the eternals and their
powers compared to marvel cinematic
universe characters we've already seen
on screen thus far let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below
does this video help you out do you have
any more questions are there any mcu
characters that i might have missed out
that maybe relate to some of these
eternal characters i would love to hear
from you guys so with that take care
stay safe follow us on facebook
subscribe to this video like it as well
and i'll chat to you soon take care
[Music]
you